des enfants et des femmes
enceintes. L'aide médicale et
humani
compte-gouttes, malgré
l'acharnement d'activistes qui
défient toutes les règles.
Marie-Ève Bédard.
- Ces images ontr,r,r,r,r,r,r,rs
de migrants qui sont toujours
massés au Bélarus à la frontière
de la Pologne. L'homme
originaire du Kurdistan irakien
par l'Union Européenne."Nous ess
inquiet pour moi-même, mais
je suis inquiet pour tousuuuuuuu
froid. Vous savez, le problème,
c'est qu'ils ne peuvenususus
tenir. On peut tenir encore
un peu, mais pas plus que
jusqu'à lundi."
"Des enfants e e e ce jeune
garçon dont les prothèses
sont maintenant brisées",
nous raconx-x-x-x-x-x-x-x-x-x-xt
à ciel ouvert, pour la plupart."
"Çaiaiaiait pas tellement de
différence", dit-il, "si on a
un sac de couchage ou pas.
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a"
La Croix-Rouge du Bélarus
ststststribue de l'eau, un peu e
nourriture et du bois pour
lutter contre le fmamamamais
rien que ne change vraiment
les conditions catastrophiques
dans lesquelle
Les soldats leur bloquent
la route, mais derrière eux,
des Polonais sont prêts
"Ils ne sont qu'à 2 km de nous",
puissent, qu'ils puissent
tout nous apporter, mais
les soldats ne laissent pas
s'approcher de la frontière.
Mais les Polonais
Ces Polonais si procheseeeeeeee
Bahadin, ce sont pour la plupart
de simples citgagagagagagés,
mais qui se sentent de plus
en plus démunis.
AcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAcAs
jetés à travers les barbelés,
les fausses couches que
dans la forêt...
Il y a... il y a deseseseseses
horribles qu'on entend.
polonais d'enfreindre
de façon systématique
le droit international et
les conventions de Genève.
- La sécurit
humanitaire et de bloquer...
et de suspendr
le fonctionnement de
la Convention de Genève.
p p p p p p p p p p p p p p p e
en Pologne.
"Si la Pologne peut tuer
parce que c'est bien de tuer
des migrants dont on parle,
nous avons déjà des morts.
Après tout, peut-être qu
des femmes ou des membres
de la communau
dit Kalina. "Il n'y a pas
de limite."
Sur Twitter, le ministère
de lolololololololonais
s'est inquiété de
ce qu'il appelle u f f f f f f t
circuler la fausse rumeur que
la Pologe e e e e e e point
d'ouvrir sa frontière et que
l'Allemagne va dépêcher
des autocars pour venir chercher
les migrants.
La Pologne a riposté en envoyant
des milliers de SMS
aux téléphones cellulaires
près de la frontière
total et un non-sens.
La Pologne continuer
protéger sa frontière",
dit le message.
"Je ne veux pas voir de gens
mourir, je ne pourrais pas
"je ne pourrais pas".
Malgré sa peur d'une escalade
qui finira vite par les achever,
dit Bahadie e e e e e e e pas
abandonner. Pas plus que
ses compagnons d'infortune.
Radio-Canada,
pr